c'est toute notre vie qui s'est écroulée
je suis d'accord
nos vies mon père a construit cette tour
c'est un symbole qui s'était fondé la
tour de télévision de Carson n'est que
ruine tout comme le reste des
infrastructures de la ville
ils ont tout détruit en partant comme un
baiser pour dire au revoir et ils osent
s'appeler des défenseurs
des défenseurs qui bombardent encore
cette ville qu'ils ont contrôlé pendant
huit mois pour les habitants de la
région difficile de supporter les traces
laissées par cette occupation comme dans
ce village au nord de Carson les troupes
russes sont transformés cette prison en
une base militaire en voyant les
prisonniers de facto libérés à Carson
Alexa est le gardien de cette prison
la boulangerie de la prison était ici
quand ils sont venus ils ont dit qu'ils
ne casseraient rien ils avaient promis
mais ils ont menti
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait je ne sais pas
dans chaque pièce ils ont même pris les
lattes du plancher les déplacements des
civils étaient strictement contrôlés
même le cimetière local était
inaccessible les obligeant à enterrer
leurs morts là où ils le pouvait
les Russes nous ont dit nous vous avons
libéré
alors moi je leur ai répondu oui vous
nous avez libéré du travail de
l'électricité du gaz de tout
même si certains soldats s'assuraient
que les habitants avaient suffisamment
de nourriture d'autres l'auront infligé
un traitement humiliant menaçant des
civils avec des mitraillettes
un gars c'est venu il nous a dit qu'il
était de là-bas et il a dit ils ne vous
ont pas assez torturé combien de temps
il te faut pour courir un 100 mètres
du jour au lendemain les troupes russes
ont fui
on n'a pas compris qu'ils avaient quitté
le village peut-être que quelqu'un l'a
vu mais c'était si rapide
au point de laisser derrière eux un
certain nombre de matériels militaires
réhabiliter par les Ukrainiens qui les
utilisent désormais contre leurs anciens
propriétaires